Hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper and it's time,
once again for the lovely Nia and a log.
Uh,
we haven't done one of these in a minute because of a certain things.
My,
a mixture of blew up when I was in Australia and then I got this stupid new
recorder and,
uh,
that I haven't been able to figure out,
but thanks to uh,
Ari Shaffir.
I just called him up and he talked me through it got me off the ledge.
So Ladies and gentlemen,
the lovely Nia.
Hi,
how are you going?
Great.
Are you,
um,
I'm actually nervous about this.
Why?
What's the,
why?
Because I have a feeling that I'm going to get trashed really badly because of,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
you might be right about that.
You are right about that.
I apologize.
Mince words.
You know what?
I apologize.
Are you want to apologize,
but I mean,
it's like,
oh Jesus,
you guys,
you're actually,
this is going to be,
this is going to be a quick one.
I don't even know if we're going to get to the advice because I don't know
thick my behavior was that bad.
Well go ahead.
Set it up near what is your
fucking promo this week?
My problem with you is that this week I planned on the prize,
the prize outing for you specifically for you,
something that you wanted to do.
And it wasn't my birthday.
It was not your birthday,
not Christmas.
Just because I love you and everything.
I know it took a lot for me to say that for some reason didn't fly out of me as
it normally does so easily.
Um,
yeah.
And so I planned this thing for you and yes,
we left the house a little bit late.
That's,
that's special.
It started.
Okay.
I'm feeling just one little thing here.
I have no idea what this is.
Price.
I'm thinking,
alright,
am I going to go to a gun range?
Is it a sports thing?
We're going to go,
uh,
is this one of those check things where it's a surprise for me,
but it's really something.
Think she wants to do like all the sudden some ballroom dancing class like,
right.
Oh boy.
And here's your shiny shirt,
sir.
I almost couldn't say that.
So anyways,
so you tell me.
Yeah,
yeah,
it's right on a so and so and so and so.
We don't name Shit here,
right.
So I'm thinking that that's not that far away.
Yeah.
We have to be there by six right?
We really had to be all the way over in east La.
Yeah.
So that what happens is we're supposed to be there by six and it's like five 58
we're stuck in traffic and I look on the,
the,
the Google map thing,
your thing wasn't working and now I see like,
we're like 10 minutes away for this thing.
I don't know what it is.
And I go,
what is it?
And she goes,
I can't tell you.
But they just said they're going to start without us.
And immediately I'm thinking like,
I'm not going to know how to load a fucking Beretta
and they're just going to hand me a loaded weapon.
And I don't know how to get to that point.
So the stress was building up for this dress was building up the traffic was
because it was that time of the night where everybody is traveling and have it,
you know.
But you know,
the way that you deal with stress is by,
I don't know,
becoming more stressed or know the way that you deal with stress is becoming
angry.
So everything became like,
it's your reaction to stress everyone.
Great stress.
No,
I,
but I don't get like angry and start becoming like this,
this,
this evil ogre of anger like you do,
which is exactly what you did.
And I,
the directions to the plays were complicated and I was trying to read them the
way they were laid out because they were laid out as specific.
No,
but it was also,
they specifically wrote it that way on the website because it was complicated
and you kept trying to involve Google maps and it was telling you that we're,
we're parking is not going to be the same as where we're going.
So anyway,
by the time we got there,
we are all in a,
what do you mean that was driving you nuts?
I was just trying to get the directions.
Your bread house.
I was just trying to get near it.
Okay.
That's fine.
Since they had,
or the computer lady and the stupid fucking cyber bitch took us the wrong a
longer fucking way and then you'll be sent to you.
So listening to that Zombie on your phone,
that way it wasn't listening to a Zombie on my phone.
I was reading the directions that were given on the website.
I was not employing the Google fucking I apple maps where it talks to you now,
which I think is a great feature by the way.
Um,
it wasn't about that.
So anyway,
but the time we got there,
you had a fucking attitude and it was supposed to be a thing where you walked
in,
you were like,
oh my God,
we're doing this.
This is amazing.
And you were like,
Eh,
it will like this fire in your eyes and like,
you know,
energy and defense.
And it wasn't even fun anymore.
We were standing next to a fucking abandoned factory.
Yeah.
It wasn't a weird
look for a white awning.
So we started walking toward rusted out hunk of Shit.
Now that I think they shot like blue collar down there and like the fucking late
seventies it's a Richard Pryor movie and we walk up and you're like,
it's not a why gardening.
I'm like,
no,
no.
And then I go,
why don't you call them?
Because I knew at one point it's 10 past six and I still don't know what I'm
doing.
All I know is I'm 10 minutes late for doing whatever the fuck I'm doing.
I go,
why don't you call him?
She just called them.
You just talked to them.
They picked up the phone and for now all of a sudden you don't want to call them
and what I want to be like,
I'm in the middle of the alley.
Which way do I go?
Like I,
I mean I knew we were near there and I didn't just want to call it the light
down factory with the giant smokestack that says so and so next to it.
All right,
fine.
But I squatted way down the way that I was putting together and I wasn't
stressed out and you were like,
you know,
barely containing your rage.
You,
you look like you were going to like wreck it Ralph mode and start punching
bricks and shit cause you would driving me fucking nuts at that point I wasn't
driving you nuts.
I wasn't doing anything but trying to get us to where we're going.
You guys are all in your head.
I got all like pumped up and you,
I see it happening with you.
I see your blood pressure rising.
I am actually looking at you and I'm seeing your blood pressure rise.
Your face is getting all red in the cheeks and you're like,
you know your jaw is tightening,
your eyes are darting back and forth.
I see.
I know what's going on.
She would drive me nuts because never mind that I am giving you this thing and
we're like,
oh no nevermind that.
You gave me this thing and you didn't elite allow enough fucking time to get to
the fucking thing.
I was trying to leave earlier and you were doing your typical thing where you
take forever to do.
Yes I am because this is a Nia log.
Typical,
typical thing.
Typical you.
You put on what I have sloping at a time at the slowest pace ever.
You like put your sucks
all slow and then you slide around the house for a little bit more going,
where am I?
Shoes,
which you know where,
where am I going?
What are we doing?
And it's taking for fucking habits.
I'll tell you why that's bullshit because you're acting like you're sitting
there and you're ready.
You're not urine.
They're putting your fucking face on.
I was telling me I had no idea what the fuck we were going,
what we were doing,
and you kept it as a surprise.
Should I wear this?
Is this okay?
Is this footwear okay?
What am I doing?
Am I going?
I told you all that and it still took you forever to get ready.
You're so full of shit.
We walked out of the house.
She left the fucking window open and the candle burning.
What does that have to do with anything?
One thing and you're bringing up something out.
This is what this is what it has to fucking do with it is if you were all ready
to go,
you would have had the fucking candle blown out and everything you wrote.
You weren't ready to either.
The other candle,
I forgot that I had two candles.
Oh,
the one that was sitting right in the table next to the fucking door.
What if that?
I blew it.
That was the Christmas one.
I bought the Christmas one,
but I didn't realize that one of the most overrated things ever having a blow
out a candle like,
oh my God,
what if that little flame leapt 200 feet as a possibility?
That's why they say you're not supposed to leave candles unattended.
That's what got Kat von D and Toronto.
It's impossible.
You have to be a fucking moron.
If you have a candle sitting in the center of a table,
you could have a 10 year Campbell candle,
right?
You can come back 10 years later and everything would be fine.
Other than the wax all over the fucking table.
It's not going anywhere.
What happens is it melts down and it create an excuse for that meat from like
sore throat here it creates like a fucking crater and it just keeps burning down
and down and down into it.
Okay.
Do you think the people at the candle store want to deal with a fucking arson
lawsuit around about arson lawsuit?
Every fucking time.
They don't.
They got them fine.
It's morons who liked them,
walk away from them and they have them underneath the curtain,
like
some little house in the prairie episode,
right?
Which I,
which I did not know what you didn't,
but you're acting like you were totally ready.
You weren't listen last there.
I love the fact he got me surprised when we tell the people what the surprise
was.
Okay,
so now,
so now we're sitting there and I go,
it's a pasta making cooking class.
I have just a pause here for all the guys would be like,
what else?
You know what?
I tweeted a picture of myself at the class last night and someone identified
your arm get bills like pasty Franco that arm out of that picture,
which I thought was hilarious.
Um,
so anyways,
so now we're walking in,
she's,
we're late for this pasta class.
You're pissed at me,
I'm mad at you.
And we come walking into this class where everybody's just like,
tell us a little bit about yourself and what you like about pasta.
And we come walking in and um,
and from there on out,
I hate a great time,
but for some reason you felt that I didn't know.
That's not true.
I think you had a good time.
I had a good time,
but it's pretty new careers.
I said this was awesome.
This is awesome.
You are very cute.
And the more,
and as we started like doing stuff like obviously our moods,
her,
then we were just having a great time and talking to people and it was fine.
I didn't embarrass you,
right?
Yeah.
Trash anybody now you did.
Well you did,
but you did it under your breath with that one girl when she poured it to
deposit thing.
Do I catch it afterwards?
No.
Let it fall on the floor.
Fucking throat.
And now it was,
it was a great time.
It was.
Uh,
but I think a lot of people can relate to that story as a couple.
You're going to do something that's supposed to be fun and something happens on
the way over there.
You come in,
you're all like tense with each other.
Like if you're going to have dinner with another couple and the other couples
lag.
Wow.
So you guys are really,
and that's what I don't understand why I would actually go to chick flicks if
they had a moment like that in the fucking movie and it was real and it wasn't
wacky.
I would enjoy that.
You know what?
I don't like that fucking dishes 40 movie where they got the dude is sitting
there taking a shit,
talking to his wife while he's on the toilet.
Right.
Amount of times they have that.
And that never happens in a relationship.
Nobody ever gets comfortable enough to be mid shit shooting the shit with
somebody.
And I don't want to fucking hear for me if you do on this podcast,
because you're part of the weird,
I could say nobody wants to fuck a dolphin and somebody's going to say,
well,
actually a friend of mine,
I'm just saying generally speaking,
they put that in war.
God Damn movies did fucking Dustin Hoffman was taking a shit while Deniro was
taken a shower and one of those meet the parents.
It's just like,
I know it's supposed to be over the top,
but I,
that to me it's,
it's a comedic device.
It's a hacky one.
It's been used too many times and it's based in absolute bullshit.
It doesn't happen.
And I,
that's my,
that's that to me,
uh,
that's the kind of comedy at fucking eight the most other than
clever eyebrow raising.
Ooh.
To say other than that shit is when you're too fucking lazy to just pull from
what's actually happened in your life.
So then you invent,
okay,
how do we add,
raise the stakes.
Oh,
he's taking his shit when he's talking to work.
Grant.
Okay.
Don't say right.
Like I've made my point.
I made it.
So anyways,
we're getting,
we get the pass the class and me because of my crust making background.
I'm fucking killing it.
You did it,
you know you did a really good job.
You were hitting your element because you like to cook.
You like to learn about these things.
You've been wiling to take a pasta making glass.
And I moved sit on your birthday this past year I found a place,
but it was too late.
It was all sold out.
So I was thinking ahead.
I read through the lines there.
I didn't give a shit enough about my boyfriend.
The fucking allot enough time.
How long does it mean?
How long does it take to sign up for a cooking class?
First of all,
listen,
stop sticking your face out at me.
If you just make the class.
It was books.
It was a present to say thank you.
Okay.
Stop turning it into,
oh well you couldn't think of it.
I'm not talking about that.
I'm talking about back in in uh oh,
what does it do for your birthday?
But to just wasn't enough time.
Well No,
I,
when I started looking at things when it,
remember your birthday this year we did a series of fun activities that you
would want to do and when I went to find a class,
everything that I look to add,
um,
all the spaces were filled up so I wasn't able to do that.
So we did all the other things for your birthday,
like the concert and the horseback riding.
Horseback riding was your birthday.
No,
that was your bro.
What's yours?
You are such a fucking liar.
Oh my God.
You're such a lying sack of shit.
Why is every fucking photo from that day about you on the God damn horse?
Because you were taking it.
I wanted to put it on my Instagram.
That was your day.
That was,
that was an activity we did for your birthday.
He didn't want to go horseback.
I want to learn to ride a horse.
I just want to sit on the fucking ridiculous.
We just sat on the God
your face out at me.
You think that makes me hear it more?
Cause you're eighth of an inch closer.
Nia.
I want to learn how to ride a horse like fucking,
oh shit.
Here comes some zombies.
Jump on a horse.
It's full fucking speed.
I don't want to just sit on it.
That's like a monkey is a class.
That's like an equestrian course.
That was for your birthday as well as house of Blues.
That was all within the same week.
The John Bonham thing.
That was the shit.
He jump on him thing that Brian Tissue think that was the shit.
Yeah,
that was great.
But the horseback riding thing,
I really think that I got that for you now.
I got that and I got it for you for your birthday.
I don't want to go horseback riding.
I like horses and everything,
but like,
you know,
whatever.
What are you talking about?
You were flipping
out every time you touched this soft muscle.
I do like the Muslim wisely.
You know what we're getting?
We're getting off track.
No one wants to hear us,
you know,
bigger as a couple that's not entertaining.
Let's move on to the next down.
Loading this.
They are in a fucking situation in their life that they,
they're getting on a fucking plane.
They wanted to keep going.
What do they want?
Entertaining.
Yeah.
All right.
They're driving into stuck in traffic.
This is what these things are for people.
Don't just like,
Hey,
I'm going to take time and I'll be able to sit down and listen to these fucking,
this is the fucking eat up time when you do DMV.
Sorry.
Right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Go on to the inlaws.
Go on the back porch.
Hour and a half.
Did you have a good time at the pasta making class that I got for you?
Right.
A fucking great time.
Now my OCD is I want to uh,
take every class now.
My mother got me that kitchen aid thing years ago and I,
I had no fucking use for it.
I didn't know how to use it.
And now that I know how to do that,
like a,
but you want to hit the typical fucking scam of these corporate cons.
I asked the lady,
not really who was teaching the class.
I will stop it.
I'll ask the lady who was teaching the class about buying the attachments.
Right.
And uh,
you know,
cause I want to make sketti right.
And she goes,
oh well they have like,
you know,
cause I like the linguine one and I liked the one where you make the Ravioli.
So they have the attachment.
It you basically you buy it through kitchenaid.
There's a whole clump of them that you get the uh,
you get the Ravioli,
you get the fucking Linguini.
And then there's like angel hair,
pasta,
like anybody each that shit.
And then a couple others.
But the spaghetti one is sold separately.
Ah Yeah.
Cause they know everybody wants to spaghetti one.
But you're still gonna want Linguini and,
and the,
and the fucking other shit.
So,
I mean it's pretty much this,
I mean,
I know it's wider or whatever then spaghetti is,
but it's kind of like this.
There's no fucking no,
it's like a four cylinder versus a fucking three 50.
It's,
it's,
it's underpowered pasta.
It's bullshit.
It's,
it's,
I don't even,
what is it for?
What is what for Angel Hair?
Pasta,
eating hair.
I like angel hair.
Pasta.
It's nice since then.
And you know,
I don't know.
It's just nice.
So good.
Throw that in there.
Everybody knows you want the spaghetti one.
Well I can look at it in a positive way.
Like maybe I just want to make spaghetti,
but why would you stop?
I don't know.
Why would you stop there?
Well,
I'm going to go get that attachment now.
Well we can't go get it because you're taking your little fucking bootcamp,
right?
Yes,
I am starting tomorrow.
I am doing a six weeks,
six week,
six weeks,
six weeks.
I have my stupid Invisalign and it's messing with my teeth.
Um,
I'm doing a six week bikini body bootcamp at the place where I,
it's hey kickboxing and um,
I'm like half excited,
half,
like not excited.
I mean I'm not Kinda like
me walking into the pasta class up to fighting through rush hour traffic.
Uh,
sure.
So I am a pill.
You want to take a cooking class right in the middle of rush hour.
Traffic will leave with a half hour.
Oh my God.
I was an asshole there.
As long as you agree that the horseback riding thing was for you.
It was not for me,
and I won't agree to this guys.
It's all or nothing with her.
She doesn't see compromiso bootcamp.
Six weeks commit.
Every Saturday we have a workout or weigh in,
there's a meal plan that goes along with it.
You know,
the whole idea is that you're,
you know,
optimal weight loss program for six weeks.
So I'm doing this thing.
So some guy's going to be screaming at you with his hands on his,
on your thighs,
adjusting you.
Is that basically,
oh,
I wish.
No,
it's a,
it's a woman.
It's a woman,
a really nice woman who does it,
but she's really tough to know.
She's like 30 something.
My son,
the way you said that,
she's a really nice woman.
She's a woman.
This just the way you said it,
you made it sound refer to every woman,
whether she's 80 or eight years old,
a girl.
Is that true?
That is true.
Is that offensive?
Well,
it's a little,
I mean,
if we were talking about Maya Angelo,
you'd be like,
that girl writes some great poems and you would say that about Maya fucking
Angelou.
Yes you will.
You head no,
but you will say you call women girls all the time.
I don't call old women girls.
You called your mom and you said your mother,
you've,
when you've referred to her,
you said girl,
at one point
that was a slip of the tongue.
Okay,
well then maybe it was a slip at the top girl.
I called my mother a girl.
Hey girl,
I'm just making up this shit about making up shit.
You say the word girl for women all the time.
When you should say a woman,
it's not offensive per se.
Well then get it off my fucking ass about it,
but I'm getting another thing.
Am I gonna call a blogger?
You would call Oprah girl.
You would,
you would call Hillary Clinton a girl.
No,
I wouldn't call it Clinton.
I call her Oprah.
Those they,
they've,
they've attained me knowing their name status despite the fact that not in my
life.
You just making up shit.
I'm not making them do it while I'm taking a shit talking to you in this
relationship.
No,
of course not.
But yeah.
Bootcamp.
So I don't know.
I don't know if anyone at camp,
I want to answer what I say.
I was working with this lady well before he started getting on the whole lady
thing.
He said,
girl,
a lot.
Trust me.
You did.
Oh,
really?
What else did I use to do that?
You still would know you.
You know what I mean?
This is what these neo logs are going to be above.
All right?
You want to get to the uh,
yeah.
Well,
I want to,
I want to hear from people.
Listen,
don't get to fucking bootcamp.
What do you mean on me?
I'm not going to get to diesel
with the whole thing.
That's going to be this ridiculous diet plan.
Jay,
hopefully there'll be a journalist jr a cheat day so that I can enjoy some nice
home.
Get to Serena on me.
Cirina.
It looks amazing if she doesn't have clothes on,
but when she starts wearing like when you get fucking big like that,
you remember
back in the 80s when everyone got all roid it up?
The only time those guys look like they were in shape as if they were standing
there in speedos.
The second they put on a suit,
they look fat.
Hmm.
They look fad.
Yeah.
You get too big.
I think it looks awesome and her ass won't quit.
Let me tell you something about that girl,
but has anyone done a boot camp?
Especially girls like we have to do a meal plan.
Do you end up sticking by that shit because it's a six week thing.
So you think,
all right,
this is six weeks in my life.
That's not forever.
That's not so bad.
I can hold off on boozing and desserts for six weeks.
It's not like I'm never going to be able to have them again.
But do you just go right back to where you were before or is it like,
is six weeks enough to ingrain in your brain?
This is how you should be living your life for the rest of your life now?
No.
You're going to live at one way for fucking six weeks,
30 years.
You can live your life one way for like 30 fucking years and then and then all
of a sudden it's six weeks.
You're going to turn around.
Well,
we'll see.
It's tomorrow's the first day.
I'm not trying to shit,
I'm just saying you're not just going to go there for six weeks and be like,
all right,
well I got that down.
You've got to keep doing it.
That's what sucks about working out and eating like shit is the easiest fucking
thing on the planet.
Well,
I mean I don't completely eat like shit,
but I definitely have my wait till I get that pasta attachment.
I know at how great was the fucking Linguini.
Yeah,
it was great.
We made linguine.
I'll just wait until a dill linguine.
You're not going to make homemade pasta and not give me any.
That's ridiculous.
Ridiculous.
Oh,
we made this Gel linguine with a vodka salmon sauce and it was fantastic.
It was fantastic.
All right.
You know what's funny?
When we went around the room where we had to share,
we would just like,
what?
Okay,
what is your name?
How did you get here and what is the last kick ass meal you had?
I thought that was cute.
It was,
and I was looking at you going,
God,
I wish I was like,
Nia.
What?
I was just like,
that's cute.
I just thought,
oh gee.
But it was,
my name is Hank.
Uh,
I was drinking around the corner and I saw the light on and the last thing I
added was a fucking hot dog and it just gives a shit bond over food.
I know.
You're right.
It was awesome.
All right.
I'm now paranoid that the chef is going to hear this and they think that I'm an
asshole,
but evidently you already do.
So who cares?
All right.
Okay.
Here we go.
Uh,
uh,
I would also like,
okay,
Bill,
sorry for the lengthy email.
I would also like to hear Nias opinion if possible.
Thank you.
That's what I'm here for.
Okay.
I dated this lady.
He actually says,
girl,
evidently a lot of people do it.
I dated this girl dated the girl of my dreams.
Don't want ever says the woman of their dreams.
If you notice that,
Ooh,
Ooh.
I dated the girl of my dreams from the
time I was 18 to 21 she was my best friend.
We rarely had fights and when we did,
they were constructive.
The sex was great.
She got a,
this is like too perfect.
She supported me in my art and music endeavors.
We like all the same movies and shit.
Got along with the family,
blah,
blah.
I'm 22 now and we've been broken up for a little over a year.
Our breakup came as a surprise to both of us.
I broke up with her because I wanted to go out and date other girls and just
enjoyed the single life I felt like I owed.
I owed that to myself to explore and final and find myself a little.
Um,
Nia,
don't text during this.
This person's asking for your advice.
What are you doing?
You're on the phone.
I'm trying to find it so I can look at it too.
I have thought about most every,
I thought about her most every day since we broke up.
I like if he says it was a surprise to both of us when he broke up with her.
Um,
I have something to say about that.
I know that look,
brace yourself,
sir.
I just kicked the recorder.
Sorry.
Um,
blah,
blah.
I think I've thought about almost every day since we broke up.
I had to tell myself it was for the best,
but,
but always hope we get back together one day.
And on a side note,
if it's not,
it's not like I needed a best friend.
I have plenty of good male friends.
She just happened to be a girl I fell in love with and be super awesome.
Uh,
by this point in the email,
I get the feeling you think I'm a pussy.
Fuck you.
I'm not a easy,
they're defensive.
I didn't say that.
Um,
while I was out being a man whore,
she was busy getting right back into a relationship.
They'd been dating for eight months or so.
I hate the guy.
Of course.
I don't really think they have anything too special.
Anyway.
Uh,
we've been talking a lot lately after basically no contact whatsoever for the
first year,
we pretty much went back to being great friends.
We've actually gotten coffee and breakfast together.
Oh Gee,
gee,
here we go.
And I'm pretty sure her boyfriend doesn't know about it.
She's even come over to my house a couple of times.
Parentheses,
we haven't done anything.
Okay.
I'll believe that.
Uh,
she knows why we broke up and understands and thinks it was important for both
of us.
We've talked about all aspects of our relationship,
including how great things were and even our sex life,
I have enough restraint to keep my dick in my pants.
Plus I know she would never cheat on the guy should I tell her how I feel?
Do you think it was unwise?
It's unwise to get back in a relationship with her.
Do you,
do I move on?
I know that's always,
wait a minute.
I know that I'll always wanted to get with other girls,
but do I really need to go out and bleed my dick dry to finally be ready for a
serious relationship with someone I could see spending the rest of my life with
a thanks to reading a love the podcasts.
All right.
When he got Whoa,
Jesus,
look at that.
Look.
What do you got to say though?
What I have to say is that you are an image.
Sure.
A selfish jerk face.
That's exactly what I think you are and isn't he supposed to be fine,
but I can still call a spade a spade.
You're an immature,
selfish jerk face.
Now,
wait a minute.
Are you just saying this because you cause you're putting,
you're inserting yourself into this situation.
You would have been the one who got your heartbroken.
No,
because I've been that person and I was an insensitive,
selfish jerk face.
Oh,
okay.
Well,
it would've been nice if you said like me.
I was waiting for the big reveal.
She's talking about herself.
Yeah.
Well,
obviously when you're that young,
you're not thinking forever.
I mean,
maybe you do in the beginning because that's what the movies and TV tell you.
I'm going to be with this person forever,
but inevitably need to take a shit in front of her.
Right?
But inevitably,
yeah,
you're going to,
especially as a guy,
in my case,
I am a girl,
you,
you think I want to go out and see what the whole world has to offer.
And then what you find as it is in life and you get older,
is that that can sometimes be a very empty pursuit.
And unless you end up finding somebody while you're whoring around,
as you say,
that is like,
wow,
you're even better and understand me even more than the last person,
you're going to feel empty and like it's not really worth it.
So of course that's what you discovered.
So of course,
because you're a selfish jerk,
you want to go back to your ex girlfriend and be like,
oh,
you know,
now we're hanging out.
Now we're friends.
She's hanging out with me.
I'm sure her boyfriend doesn't know about it,
but she would never cheat it because she's such an angel and we even talk about
our sex life.
Like,
what are you doing?
What are you doing right now?
Should I tell her?
Yes,
yes.
Why don't you tell her?
Why don't you fuck up her relationship that's going so well?
Why don't you just throw it in her mind that like you're still now and you want
her back?
Why don't you just act as selfish as you can possibly be?
If you really care about this girl,
you step away,
you be a man and you let her have this relationship.
If it doesn't work out with her and the guy and she comes back to you and it's
all lovely and fairytale and rainbows,
then great,
but you stay away from her.
Jesus Christ,
first of all,
they're really,
how do you feel that their relationship is going gray when she's with her
fucking ex boyfriend in the guide,
these fucking apartment?
Maybe it's not.
Well,
you just fucking roasted the guy.
Well because he's the one that's writing in saying like,
I know I'm still going to want to get with other girls will.
Obviously,
obviously you're going to want to bang other people.
That's what,
that's what happens in life.
Like I don't necessarily believe that we are these naturally monogamous
creatures,
but you do it because that's what a commitment is.
That's what growing up is.
You're committed to one person unless you have some sort of deal worked out.
Okay,
so of course you're going to want to bang other girls.
Do you need to let your hoodies a bleed your dick out before you're ready for a
relationship?
Well,
with your maturity level,
probably.
Probably sir.
So why don't you just bang a bunch of whores and get it out of your system while
pining for a girl who actually cares and he has to do what he supposed to do.
You know what he could have done?
He could have stayed with her and just fucked around on her and he did.
He should get a cookie for doing the right thing.
Congratulate fucking lesions.
Jesus Christ.
But you're,
you're acting like he's fucking immature.
That's a real mature move that he did that he was like,
listen,
I want to see other people.
I don't want to cheat on you.
I mean that's pretty fucking matured.
Mature.
He's 22 years old.
He supposed to want to fuck everything.
That's what I say.
And he should go out there and go do it.
Yeah.
He said,
but I don't like,
I don't like this whole,
you know Ron,
the girl back in his book,
I shouldn't do this bullshit.
And I know you haven't talked for the first year.
So I mean if you haven't talked for a year,
that's,
that's a,
that's a good amount of time to stay awake.
I think what he's doing,
but he's trying to have his cake and eat it.
Wouldn't drawn are drawn her.
So her feelings for this other guy won't get too deep.
You know,
he'll fuck up their relationship or whatever.
And you know,
this girl,
you dated her for three years,
you know exactly how her brain works.
You know exactly what buttons to push.
Like don't try to act like this is such a like,
oh naturally now we're friends again.
It's like of laying the seeds for this for a while.
I feel like,
and I don't think that that's right because you're not really allowing her to
have a relationship.
If she has,
if she's hanging out with you and your home and he doesn't know about it,
that's,
that's a problem.
Right?
That's a problem.
Extra spiffy when she came over,
but not too much spiffy and other talking about their sex life.
Why are you talking about your sex life?
Why is your ex girlfriend,
was she doing it or unless he's emailing and emailing,
I would be like,
what you're doing?
Let's he steered it in that direction.
He did.
I know we had to break up.
I know it was you and Noah,
you understand?
No,
you're cool.
So you totally,
you totally get it.
But like,
I don't know,
sometimes I can't help but think,
but like you and I just had this connection.
No,
no,
no.
I know you have a boyfriend then.
I'm not trying to,
I'm not trying to be weird.
This is weird that we're talking about it as this weird cause I'm not trying to
be okay.
No,
you understand.
You're so awesome.
I just,
Ah,
I blew it with you.
Didn't I know I blew it.
I blew it.
No,
I want you to be happy.
You're a fucking emotional manipulator playing games with this girl and I won't
stand for it.
All right.
I can't argue with that.
I think she's got,
you nailed that buddy.
But I don't think you're a piece of shit cause you want to go and fuck some,
a bunch of women,
not a piece of shit,
but I'm going to tell you what's the real,
okay.
The fact that you're coming back,
you're going to tell him,
when are you going to say what's real?
Being all like,
you know,
sweet and friendly and talking about your sex life with your ex girlfriend,
knowing full well she has a boyfriend and it's because it's coming from a place
where you're like,
oh shit,
I realize what I lost.
That's not,
no,
you don't do people like that.
That's wrong.
Yeah.
Then j Lo have a song about being real.
Then she
did you buy that?
Was that written by somebody else?
So did she really sit there thinking that
I was a huge halo fan?
So yeah,
I brought all her music.
You don't know why?
I didn't know why.
A clothing line,
I'm not ashamed to admit it.
Did you buy those,
those,
it was a two thousands.
Okay.
Did you buy those hoary timberlands that she used to walk?
You know what I actually did?
I wanted those,
those healed timberland boots.
What I did not realize because I was young,
I didn't know anything about designer shit,
was that it wasn't Manolo Blahnik.
And so I actually called the Timberland store is vibrating my phone.
I called it off.
What's going on?
The thing,
I'm in the middle of a thought here.
I called the Timberland store and said,
are you carrying the Timberland boots with the heels?
And they're like,
does or Manila blacks?
And I,
I didn't know.
That's obviously a really expensive shoe.
It is a very expensive shoe.
Made famous on sex and the city.
No,
that's Christian Lubitel.
Uh,
but uh,
I actually got the fake,
uh,
he'll timberlands from Steve Madden and Iraq,
those with some cargo pants.
Cause I thought I was J lo.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's terrible.
It was terrible,
but it was like,
you know,
2004 or something.
I should wash jeans when I used to watch all those hair metal bands.
I have big orange Afro.
I didn't have the orange Afro back then,
but I did.
I did it a couple of times.
Try wearing a Bandanna if I was going to go to a concert
and even I even picture you in right now.
No,
I looked,
I dunno what I look like.
I know the obvious would be like,
look like you had cancer.
I just didn't.
I was just like,
I can't do this.
Do you know what ever one time we were playing,
we used to play a pickup football.
When I was in high school.
It was all the kids who wanted to play football but didn't want to go through
the bullshit of actually having some guy,
you know,
yelling at years.
You ran around the track.
We just had a fucking great time and this one kid showed up.
He had a Bandanna tied around his head and one around his thigh.
I don't know why around his,
this upper thigh and we would call him.
Yeah.
Like Chachi like Scott Baljit is,
so we started calling them Shachi.
I think he might even had like the fingerless gloves.
Judd Nelson on exactly little bread for breakfast.
He looked bad ass though.
He looks,
you know the Bandanna,
the earrings,
the feathered hair,
the fingerless gloves.
That's one of the Credo
is in a,
in a,
uh,
t coming of age.
He was great.
He was a,
what was his name?
They're not judge Reinhold.
What's his real name?
Nelson.
Judd Nelson.
Anyone outside?
It was a judge.
Um,
all right.
What the fuck was I going to talk and do it on the boat?
Ge,
it was funny about that.
Is is uh,
what's his face?
Anthony Michael Hall who was playing the Nerd,
his name,
his character's name was Brian Johnson,
which I always thought was funny cause that's the lead singer of ac DC.
One of the baddest dudes ever.
Well that's one of the gorilla.
Do you want to,
you want to do one more of these or if you had nice.
Yeah,
I don't know if I'd do it with the next one because I already fucking read this
one,
but we'll do it.
What do you know somebody right now?
They'd probably just reach cruising altitude,
begging,
but it's when you've already answered before I answered it this week on the
podcast.
But we could hear your perspective for once in my life.
I could shut the fuck up.
Yeah.
I don't think so.
Come on.
You work on your comeback show.
Yeah,
I gotta get,
I gotta get better if I want to be with the master such as you be.
Set me up for the puppies right here and quicker with my come back.
Oh,
by the way,
uh,
the Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit February 19th,
Tuesday.
Can't wait.
That's going to be a gay man.
Going to be awesome.
I don't want to thank everybody who bought tickets last.
I heard there's like 90 left.
Yup.
Get on it.
Quit.
Everybody is going to break my balls that I didn't promote it on,
on my podcast on Monday.
It was just one of those things I wanted to,
to announce it on the opiate.
Anthony show because of what I felt that they did for Patrice,
having them on,
they're hyping his gigs and just like,
I mean there's just hours of footage of him on that show that you could watch on
youtube every day and it gives like someone who never met him,
that experience of,
of kind of what it was like to hang out with that guy.
So,
um,
I wanted to do it that way.
So for,
I get emotional.
Let's read this next one.
All right.
Hey,
bill loved the podcast back cataloguing it like crazy.
Here's my fucking problem.
I got a roommate who was wonderful.
We're buddies.
We watch stupid shit and laugh at it together.
He's got this girlfriend who was a drain on everything that fun in the world.
I'm not talking about the regular guy,
girl argument crap.
I mean everything.
Quick example,
we were watching that BBC planet Earth series and we're just looking at the most
beautiful shit in the world literally.
And all she could do is bitch about how ugly the birds were.
Complain about David Attenborough's Voice,
oh my God.
Or get mad at some animal just because it's killing another animal to survive
after we,
that would really ruin it.
Yeah,
I seen that series,
but it's supposed to be amazing,
so I'm already mad that someone would ruin it like that.
Potheads love that fucking shit.
Oh yeah,
that's,
that's all.
That's the best time to watch.
The plan was made so big,
man.
He me edgy.
If you like a plant man and like,
you know,
open up and they close down and then a bead combine,
you wouldn't be scared man.
Your friend.
Here's my flower juice and that's the thing.
That's what's so lovely is sometimes about smoking pot is that you can do silly
like good,
clean,
fun things like watch a documentary on the planet earth and just the smoke pot
and just laugh and being filled with why wish I could do that filled with
wonderment.
I wish I could do that
because I can't sit down and watch a documentary on the planet earth unless I've
taken some drugs.
Why can't you just sit there and enjoy it?
You can,
but it's more fun.
I get it.
I break the glass,
it's silly.
It's like no one smokes pot and goes out and like robs banks are not p y over.
Are you really going to go with it?
Like that hasn't been true.
People say,
well everyone says it because it's true.
It's because it's a fucking,
it just mellows you out.
Yeah,
exactly.
To the point you become party your couch and you wake up years later and you're
still sitting there eating fucking Fritos and you were all right with it.
Hey,
we're all right with it.
Don't harsh my mellow man.
Yeah.
All right.
No,
I'm not.
I'm looking.
So anyway,
this is not like booze.
Is any of this girl is being a complete wet blanket during this amazing
experience.
Way To say it.
Yes.
Um,
so anyways,
he goes after we finish this,
this documentary,
she said she would love to be a crew of a nature documentary shoot.
Um,
and anyways,
she's got no soul.
The guy loves earth.
They've been together for over a year,
but it's clear he can't stand to be around her.
The only ever argue and not the great
are you and Nia did.
And one of the podcasts where you all laughed with each other.
It's unbearable and she's at my apartment five days a week.
Most nights I eventually either drink or just smoke so I can just stay in this
so I'm not in the same world as her and I liked smoking.
Who am I kidding?
I want all,
I want to wait,
I want to talk to him about it.
But he's a really private person.
We've never talked about his relationship stuff.
He tends to steer away from it.
It becomes pretty obvious that I can't stand the girl.
It's becoming pretty.
Obviously I can't stand that girl Norkin nor can any of our friends.
I'm afraid she's going to drive us apart and then feast on his soul so she can
try to find some kind of personality for herself.
That is hilarious.
How do you like,
how do you think I should approach
this topic with this guy?
I got a right to complain to him about this girl,
right?
Yes.
Got To do a tenderly or something.
Yes,
yes to both those things.
I mean listen,
you live there too.
So if their arguments and everything are,
it's,
it's effecting your enjoyment of living in your home,
then you have every right to to say something.
It's how should we go about it?
Yeah.
Well that's the tricky part.
Just say,
you know,
do they smoke weed first?
Just say,
you know,
obviously like you're one of my best friends.
I love hanging out with you,
but I gotta be honest with you.
I'm not,
I,
I don't really get along so well with whatever the fuck her name is.
So I don't know if I'm going to be hanging out with you guys so much.
If she's over here,
I don't think I'm going to be hanging out as much and just,
just,
we'll put it like that.
Don't say I feel like you should break up with her.
I feel like she's going to rob you of your zone or feast on you or whatever you
said,
which was so great.
You don't have to say all that.
Just say,
you know what,
I'm just not really,
you know,
I don't,
I don't get along with her.
You guys fight a lot.
It's really uncomfortable.
Like there was a good one.
Yeah,
just fight a lot.
you guys fight a lot.
I hear it and I just,
it's really uncomfortable.
I just want to chill out at home.
I don't have a good time with her when we're hanging out.
I don't know what you want to do.
Can you guys hang out more at her place?
Maybe,
but I just,
this isn't working for me.
I live here too.
I pay half the rent and you're my friend so I want to,
I want to be honest with you and see what he says.
And he might probably be just be like,
yeah,
I know,
but he's got to figure that shit out for himself.
But at least you say it,
cause that's the girl that he might flip out,
he might flip out,
but unless he's calling the girl names and saying,
you know,
your girlfriends a bitch and I can't believe you're dealing with that,
Luna Tech,
then it should be fine.
But if he says,
I don't really get along with her,
I don't have a good time when she's here.
You guys fight.
And I just,
I'm not into it and maybe we can work out a different schedule so that you hang
out a bit more at her place because I live here too.
That's it.
That's a very nice way of saying,
yeah,
girl is a big bag of Douchey.
Yeah.
And the thing is your friend knows it too and,
but it may be a good thing too,
because no one else is saying it to him.
So I actually do you do that?
How you tell your friend that they're dating an asshole?
It's a,
it's a tough situation.
I didn't have the balls to break up what you just said.
I think it was way better than what I was saying on the part.
I remember what the fuck I said,
but just go in there and just saying,
listen,
you know,
I like you.
I want you to be happy.
But you and your girlfriend,
you argue a lot.
And it it,
it's wearing me down and I'm finding that I'm medicating myself so I can be
around it and I don't want to be around it.
I'm not saying she can't come over here.
I'm not saying that,
but if there's any way,
you know,
she's over here five days a week,
there's any way he could just split those.
Yeah.
You know and you know,
if you love this girl then I'm not going to get in a,
we never trashed the girl.
That's a huge,
don't have a trash trash the girl.
I mean inevitably he,
if he goes along with it the room and says okay,
you're right,
he will have to say that the girlfriend,
you know what,
let's hang out.
But I like hanging out here a place.
Well you know my roommate kind of just wants time to themselves.
What's that supposed to mean?
Oh,
[inaudible] asking to go right off and flip out regardless.
You know,
cause he's going to tell her.
Yeah,
he has solo.
He asked him.
He doesn't have to.
If he's a smart guy,
he won't say Shit.
What will he,
how will they do at though?
Just say let's take out of your house going to create a nightmare.
That's what fucking broke up the Beatles.
That's what broke up the Beatles is John.
And Paul kept going home and bitch under their fucking girls about each other
rather than just fucking hash it out between themselves.
And then the fucking women got sick of hearing it and they said,
well then fucking start your own band.
Right.
You fucking driving me nuts and everybody blames Yoko and fucking uh,
what's your face?
But you know that video I showed a long time ago where,
what's his face,
John Lennon is playing guitar with Chuck Berry and they're playing some fucking
song from back in the 50s that,
you know,
inspired like John Lennon I guess to pick up the guitar like they loved Chuck
Berry and then only play in one of those fucking uh,
you know,
back in the USA kind of fucking songs.
And Yoko is out a little control.
He had his relationship.
He lets Yoko be in the band on TV playing with them playing bongos and they have
this little fucking Bango with one microphone on it and out of the fuck was the
sound guy,
but he should have had the mic off cause they're in the middle of this fucking a
one two three o'clock,
four o'clock probably kind of fucking old school rock and roll song and she just
grabs the mic and watch your ears.
Everybody.
I'm going to try not to it too loud.
She just goes
like
fucking,
I didn't know where to look on Chuck Berry's face
is priceless.
He just looks at the crowd with his eyes wide open and you know exactly what
he's saying.
He is.
He is this guy in this email,
in that fucking video.
He's basically looking at the crowd.
Go on.
I don't know what he sees in her.
I can't say shit.
He loves her.
I would like to see the looks on the people's faces that he used to pee on Chuck
Berry.
I'd like to see that.
What the willing people who are into that stuff.
I thought you didn't judge people.
I don't judge people,
but that's awful.
Why are you,
why are you judging them for that?
And I actually thought he took pictures of people taking dumps.
He did.
I didn't know about that then.
I don't know why he just peed on people.
Well,
look,
you're a rockstar.
You've done everything.
You checked everything off the list.
What else can I do to this girl?
And they let him,
and it's a legitimate thing that some people are into nine.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Yes.
I try to be tolerant and I try not to judge.
You're just mad because once again,
this is a,
this is a lady,
I actually blamed the fucking Beatles breaking up on Paul and John.
Can I get credit for that?
I got,
okay,
well then can you lease roll with me that you
kill the fucking classic song?
No,
you're right.
You're right.
But I just was thinking of Chuck Berry and I just remember hearing that he used
to pee on people and you said Chuck Berry is reaction.
And it made me think of,
I wonder what the reaction was as he is,
you know,
sorry.
It's actually funny and it goes from like,
oh my God,
I'm fucking like,
you know,
Rock Blues,
Guitar,
God,
Chuck Berry,
and now he's paying on me.
And this was back in the day before people would talk about this and it was
known that it was,
you know,
this was a real taboo things and I talked to them.
Margin,
you're having sessions guide and all of a sudden he starts peeing on you.
That's like a new thing.
No,
no,
not new.
It's new that people are discussing more openly.
I don't think back in,
when was he big?
50th sixties like didn't the Greeks like openly talk about homosexuality like
fucking a thousand fucking years ago.
Didn't they do that then?
They may be,
they had a room just for you to go on and throw up and after you fucking eight
look like put people then.
But people like in the fifties and sixties they weren't necessarily talking
about how common
it is for people to do it on a p on the golden age of television,
they didn't talk about golden shower.
Speaking of a golden age,
let's talk about a new trends I had a long time ago.
I hide this drum teacher and I actually put this in that book that we wrote.
And uh,
this guy was like 70 years old or something.
I had a girlfriend and I missed a lesson and he said,
ah,
he goes a stiff prick,
has no conscious,
and he was breaking my balls and he goes,
so what?
She looked like,
let me here.
So I told them the story.
So he starts laughing and he starts telling me this fucking story of how a 72
year old guy,
all right,
this is a back end,
like the fucking nineties so you know,
this guy was born in the,
in the 20s and he was telling the story.
He goes,
yeah,
he used to bang this blonde haired green eyed chick in the park up against the
tree and blah.
And I sat there with my fucking jaw on the ground cause I'm looking at,
the guy looked like Santa Claus
and then he just,
I was like,
people did that back then.
And he just said,
he's like,
let me tell you something kid.
Every generation thinks they're the first generation that ever,
fuck.
And you went on this whole blog thing,
everything's been done.
It's all fucking,
you know.
And so I don't think,
uh,
you know,
I'm not defendant doing something like that,
but it's definitely not a new phenomenon.
But I spoke fucking Chuck Berry.
We have a little respect here.
I absolutely,
absolutely fucking peed on her inner mouth.
She sounded like she was getting peed on.
Maybe that's why he's eyes fucking went wide.
He was probably getting roused.
Oh,
Jesus.
All right,
we're going to end on that.
All right.
That's the Nia log.
Hope you guys enjoyed it.
And,
uh,
I hope you had a happy post Thanksgiving week.
Happy holidays.
Let me buddy.
Oh,
that's what you said.
That's what you said.
And,
uh,
you're,
when I was talking to me again,
I had thanksgiving for breakfast and that was the best,
and everybody just fucking has always flies right to you.
Like a Goddamn light.
Everybody loves you.
Who doesn't relate to have leftovers for breakfast?
What about him?
We went to no doubt that concert,
right?
Yeah.
We went to go see trashed.
I went to a no doc content pasta make possibly make the very next night and I
ever dealt.
We went horseback riding on my birthday because we're a couple,
we do couple type cutesy shit near this is 50 fucking minutes long.
The epilogue is 15 minutes long.
Oh No,
we should end it.
Yeah,
All right.
You guys go fuck yourselves.
See you.